cent vingt mille ordinateurs de plus
dans les écoles avant la prochaine
rentrée il y en a actuellement 40 milles
c'est le plan lancé cet après midi par
le premier ministre laurent fabius un
plan de 2 milliards de francs pour
initier petits et grands au mystère de
l'ordinateur reste à savoir si
l'intendance suivra
daniel durand des créé onze mille
ateliers informatiques comme celui ci
est équipé de six micros ordinateurs de
type familial reliés en réseau à un
élément central semi professionnel c'est
la logistique du plan fabius de la micro
pour qu'ils informatique est un élément
essentiel à la modernisation du pays
la solution matérielle retenu par le
gouvernement et 100% française les
outils de base choisie sont les canines
et thomson le mo5 véritable r5 de la
micro et le to7 70 outil encore plus
performant relié au micral 32 bull
véritable cerveau de ces ateliers
informatiques
parallèlement à cette implantation un
plan de formation systématique de
l'enseignant va être engagée il devrait
être 150000 initié au langage
informatique d'ici la fin de l'année
on ne peut former les 11 millions
d'enfants
et puis le public que si il y à des
formateurs
on a déjà fait un gros effort mais il
faut passer la vitesse accélérée ça veut
dire donc à partir de
les prochaines semaines il va y avoir
deux d'une série de sessions formations
ouvertes pour les entités ça veut dire
que les enseignants prendront sera temps
de congés peut-être pour les enseignants
d'après les contacts que nous avons eus
sont prêts à faire un producteur qui
sera dédommagée comme c'est normal mais
je pense qu'ils ont le souci d'être à
l'avant-garde de la modernisation autres
lignes force du plan fabius
l'ouverture de ces ateliers
d'informatique à tous en dehors des
heures scolaires
reste le problème des logiciels c'est à
dire des bibliothèques informatique là
un effort considérable devra être fait
par les visiteurs mais aussi par les
auteurs aujourd'hui 250 logiciels sont
en cours d'adaptation à la rentrée
scolaire 500 devrait être disponible
maintenant au delà de toute volonté
politique
c'est à la matière grise et créateurs
informatique de jouer